I can't give blood because they have a tightness.
Which one do you get?
B or c a.
Is that a good one?
Yeah,
that's the,
that's the one miss easy one.
Oh that's nice.
Yeah.
It was like a month down yellow eyes.
Like no energy a month.
That was,
yeah,
that uh,
that's a long story.
But that,
that I actually got it from a guy who was sort of saving me from something else
that I,
they never told you the whole Scorpion and Guatemala story.
I think you did.
But tell me again.
Well,
it's a long story.
Yeah.
I mean,
and you don't now though.
People will be,
well I feel like they're getting,
people can hear it.
I,
I've told her on my podcast and I've also,
I told her it on a podcast called risk and I,
that's actually cliff notes.
Uh,
yeah,
but listen to the risk thing.
If anyone would see,
hear the whole thing cause they added sound effects and it's really good.
What is risk?
It's a,
it's a podcast.
It's called,
it's a storytelling thing,
you know,
it's like the moth.
It's that kind of thing.
And they added sound effects and they produced it really well.
Yeah,
as well.
Yeah.
What happened was I was,
I was with my girlfriend at the time,
Puerto Rican,
super beautiful Puerto Rican girl.
She tried to get you to go to a camp away and talk about Jesus or,
no,
she never tried to talk to me about Jesus,
but I would have listened because she was interested in how the APP,
no,
she was great.
Um,
so I was with her and Guatemala and,
uh,
we had met this other couple,
um,
Solange and,
uh,
Fabrizio.
Whoa.
And,
um,
yeah,
we were at this place called t Carl in a North East Guatemala,
way,
way back in the jungle.
And it's a Mayan ruins.
Beautiful,
crazy.
You know,
it was like a big city and now they're,
you know,
when I was there,
this was 1989,
there were maybe 10 big ruins,
big temples that they had uncovered.
And,
uh,
we're staying in this camp site with hammocks.
It was very primitive at the time.
Anyway.
Uh,
we,
it was a full moon and Ana and I decided we were going to take some acid and
watch the moonrise and the sunset up from the top of tumble for,
it's called the Jaguar temple.
And so we went up with this other couple and there's this ledge up there and
it's up above tree line.
You know,
you're way above the tree line.
You can see the monk here are the monkeys and,
and like see out over this flat jungle,
the Battan,
I think it's called.
And um,
so we're up there and the sun's sinking and the moon is rising and the moon
comes up and it's beautiful.
And,
and there's this big bank of storm clouds and the full moon is like between the
horizon and the storm clouds,
but then it starts to go up behind these clouds and you can see it's going to
get dark as fuck.
Right?
So this other couple like,
yeah,
we're going to go back to the camp side.
They didn't know we were tripping.
Right.
And we timed it.
So we were peeking like now.
And so they're going to go back to the camp sites.
So we,
but we were like,
yeah,
we're going to just hang here.
Right.
So I went over to hold the flashlight for them as they went down this ladder.
He was like maybe a 30 foot ladder,
pipe ladder drilled into this,
the temples made out of limestone blocks.
And so to get up there,
yeah,
there you go to before.
So we're at steep.
Yeah.
Is that type of climbed up?
Does that temple for though?
The Jaguar example?
I typed in temple for Jaguar.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah.
When I was there it was much more overgrown.
Anyway,
so we,
we went up to the top of it.
That looks like it.
They're on the right.
Yeah.
That looks like it from like when we were there anyway,
so we're up on that ledge there and uh,
and see how flat the the jungle is.
It just goes forever.
It's so crazy how it's almost like uniform and height.
Yeah.
I mean it's just very,
very little bit,
but oh,
look at that picture.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
It looks like a picture I took actually up there.
Um,
anyway,
so it's so beautiful.
So we're up there and,
uh,
and I'm holding the ladder for these guys going down and they're like,
okay,
we're good.
I'm like,
okay.
I turned off the ladder and I take a step and fuck,
oh,
what the fuck was that?
I turned the flashlight back on.
I see the Scorpion going up the wall,
stirring up the wall like four inches green.
And then they're like three other ones on the wall.
It's like,
fuck this things crawling with fucking scorpions.
And I just got stung on the toe while you're on acid while I'm tripping and
thank God I didn't jump cause I would've dropped 30 feet to fucking rocks,
you know,
God.
So I go back to ana and I was like,
Shit.
She said,
what happened to you?
I said,
I just fucking Scorpion.
Like,
watch out and like,
oh Jesus.
Right.
Oh my God.
So we're kind of like,
oh,
are they dangerous?
I don't know.
Are they?
So,
um,
now it's getting dark,
right?
Cause the moon's going behind these clouds and there's this other,
these two dudes like way over on the other side of the ledge and we go over to
them and they're Italian and they don't speak English,
but honest spoke Spanish.
So she was talking to them in Spanish and Italian and you could sort of
understand,
you know,
they're both Latin,
similar languages and those guys are like,
ah,
I don't know.
And we were like,
watch out cause they're all around like,
oh shit.
Yeah.
So while we're talking to them now it's totally dark.
This Guatemalan dude comes up the ladder with an old bolt action rifle and he's
like the night guard or something.
So we go over to him and honest as to him in Spanish,
um,
is sewn belly,
some petty gross was a Scorpio and they got,
are they dangerous?
The Scorpions and the guy says [inaudible],
I'm worth those.
Oh they're lethal.
They're deaths.
Oh my God.
Fuck man.
I understood enough Spanish to get that thinking.
You're dying.
So I'm like,
yeah,
this is this.
Is it April,
full moon of April,
1989 yeah,
I was 27 it was right around the time of Trump's plane crashed.
What if it was exactly the same?
I think talking about being mercury was in racism in your life.
Yeah.
I was at a table with that Puerto Rican girl.
Why would you,
where would that other Puerto Rican girl up there?
Porter remained.
Girls crossed our path.
We both survived.
She was barely.
So what happened to you?
So I'm thinking like,
fuck,
I got to get down from here because there's no way anyone else could carry me
down the ladders and you couldn't get a stretcher down.
Right.
So if I'm going to survive,
I got to get down on my own quickly.
So then they fight collapsed.
They can get an ambulance,
all that.
We're like,
you know,
two days from Guatemala City and whatever the town was.
I don't even know if they had a clinic or I don't know.
But we were pretty remote and I'm like,
they're not going to send out a helicopter or some shit like that.
Right?
So,
uh,
I get down,
I,
oh,
so what happens is my girlfriend's freaking out.
Um,
no,
no criticism of her.
I think it's much harder to watch someone you love die than to die yourself.
And in this case.
And so she's like,
Oh fuck,
you're dying.
And I'm thinking,
Gee,
maybe.
And so the one of the Italian dudes is like,
look,
you guys go,
I'll stay with her and make sure she's all right.
And so I go down with his other Italian dude.
We go down the ladder and we get down to the floor.
We started walking around the jungle and it's fucking totally dark now.
Cause the moon's totally obscured.
And the jungle,
you know when you're tripping,
you're,
your pupils are super dilated so you can see light and stuff that normally you
might miss.
Like the jungle in Guatemala was full of glowing worms and shit flying by.
It's all like green and we're and,
yeah.
Yeah.
And they're like these caterpillars and like really shit,
this place is wild.
So we're walking around lost,
totally dark tripping.
I'm tripping.
He doesn't know I'm tripping.
How,
how trip and Aria tripping.
That was three head nods,
ladies and gentlemen.
I mean,
you know,
I'm peeking from the acid plus all the adrenaline,
right?
And so this pain is running up my leg.
And as it,
it's like running up the bone in the center of the leg.
This is kind of fire.
And when it gets to the top of muscles,
they've seize up.
So like,
you know my from the knee down,
it's just like rigid.
And I,
and then my tongue starts swelling and my throat starts swelling.
And I got this like novacane feeling and my lips and I'm sorta drooling.
And um,
and I'm thinking when this gets to my heart,
that's when I die.
And so I'm,
I'm with this guy and we're lost.
And,
and at first you're like,
I'm freaked.
I'm look scared.
And then it occurs to me that I'm saying my last words to a guy whose face I've
never seen,
cause we didn't shine the light in his face.
And we were talking to him
and he doesn't understand English.
And that cracks me up that I just,
I start laughing like a fucking maniac and he's like,
got his arm around me.
He thinks I'm like losing it.
And I'm just like,
this is hilarious.
And I think about my friends and how they're going to be like,
yeah,
you know,
good on Chris.
You know,
he didn't die in some dumb ass way.
Like we all thought he would.
He died in this.
It's still a dumb ass way,
but at least it's interesting.
And then I started thinking,
you know,
all right,
I'm 27 but I've been around the world.
I literally around the planet,
I've been in love.
I've had sex with gorgeous women who loved me,
who,
you know,
I've,
well,
I made a shit ton of money.
I walked away from it.
I,
I've done,
I've done everything I wanted to do.
I'm 27 but I've done everything and I've had a fucking amazing life.
Wow.
And this is cool.
I would have been crying like a bitch,
I believe.
Not.
Yeah.
You know,
I felt really bad for my parents and,
and Ana.
But for myself,
I was like,
I've had a good fucking run.
It's not as long as I would've liked,
but I've had a good fucking run.
So I,
I really came to this piece and like,
the world doesn't owe me shit,
man.
I've had,
I mean,
I'd been in Alaska two summers at that point.
I worked in New York,
in Manhattan for two years at that point with a guy who offered me $1 million if
I would stay.
And I said No.
And I left.
I flew to India.
I had been in Asia for two years.
You've said no to a million bucks when I was 26.
Why did you say no to a million bucks?
What was the catch was you need to do,
do you know he was a really good guy actually.
Uh,
I liked him a lot.
Um,
the million bucks was,
he said,
when you're 30,
you'll have a net worth of $1 million.
And if you don't,
I'll write you a check for the whatever you're missing and we'll notarize it.
And this guy's worth $30 million or something.
So he just wanted you to work for him.
He wanted me to stay and I wanted to go.
I wanted to see the world.
And this guy hired me to help him manage his family's property in midtown
Manhattan.
And the main reason he hired me is because I didn't give a shit about money,
so he knew I wouldn't steal from him.
Ah,
that's interesting.
And when it stopped being fun and knew,
I was like,
I gotta go.
And he's like,
no,
stick around.
I'll make it worth your while.
And so there was this weird dynamic.
But anyway,
I,
I'd had all these experiences and so I was like,
Hey,
I've had a good run.
So anyway,
we finally,
we come out into this little parking lot and there's this Guatemalan kid there
maybe 10 or something,
and the Italian guy talks to him and says,
Scorpion,
Scorpion.
And the kid looks at me like,
oh my God,
come,
come.
And he takes us to this trailer and we bang on the door and this horrible
fluorescent light comes on.
And this like Guatemalan Dude who obviously had been drunk and asleep,
you know,
it was like what?
And like the kid says he's the doctor,
he's not a doctor,
he's some jungle dude,
whatever.
And the,
so the guy takes us in and he's talking,
you know,
it's sort of just Saki,
broken English.
And I explained to him,
he says,
how big is the Scorpion?
He looks at my foot,
he says,
how big was the Scorpion?
I said,
yeah,
like this big,
like a finger and what color?
Gray,
green sort of.
And he says,
ah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's not a scorpion.
That's electron.
So in Spanish and that part of Guatemala anyway,
they're two different words.
A beyond is a little red thing.
[inaudible] is a big green thing,
but they're both with the tail in know.
And uh,
so we had been using the word Scorpion because in English that's all there is.
But Scorpion,
a Scorpion in that part of Guatemala is lethal.
And that's a little tiny thing.
That's a little red thing and that will fucking take you out.
But the guys like,
look,
you're still,
this was two hours ago and you're still alive.
You'll be fine.
Apparently it's like if you have a bad heart or you're a kid,
maybe this'll kill you,
but if you're,
if you survive a couple of hours,
you're going to be Ra.
Speak fucking take you out.
But the guys like,
look,
you're,
this was two hours ago and you're still alive.
You'll be fine.
Apparently it's like if you have a bad heart or you're a kid,
maybe this will kill you,
but if you're,
if you survive a couple of hours,
you're going to be all right.